je vous invite tout d'abord à découvrir
quelques images illustrant la richesse
exceptionnelle de la biodiversité
calédonienne son lagon qui appartient au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco est
considéré comme un des plus beaux du
monde
le cagou l'oiseau emblématique de
nouvelle calédonie la mangrove et le
coeur de vos sont l'objet de
photographies qui circulent dans le
monde entier
88 % des espèces végétales de nouvelles
quêtes denis sont uniques
on ne les trouve nulle part ailleurs
lent borella cet ancêtre de tous les
arbres à fleurs y est encore présent si
l'on visite la forêt tropicale on peut y
trouver des espèces très particulières
telles que cet arbre à l'acef bleus qui
est devenue une curiosité mondiale cette
couleur bleue est d'ailleurs le témoin
d'un phénomène rare la longue histoire
géologique de la nouvelle-calédonie
engendré des quantités importantes de
nickel dans le sol le nickel etc
toxiques pour les plantes
ainsi cet arbre pour survivre a dû
développer des stratégies d'adaptation
mais aujourd'hui il accumule en
permanence que nickel jusqu'à 20% dans
sa sève tout cette couleur bleue puis le
stock dans ses feuilles comme pour mieux
s'en protéger la richesse du nickel en
nouvelle-calédonie est telle qu'elles
représentent 25 % des ressources
mondiales
l'extraction de ce minerai est donc
extrêmement importante
on estime qu'elles pourraient atteindre
jusqu'à 40% du pib s'agit donc
clairement d'une ressource vitale pour
le territoire calédonien
malheureusement l'extraction du minerai
est également très destructeur pour la
biodiversité calédonienne toutes les
mines sont à ciel ouvert la première
étape consiste à éliminer la végétation
et à détruire l'horizon supérieur
fertile on estime aujourd'hui qu'il y à
plus de 23 mille hectares de surfaces
dégradé par les extractions minières les
seuls sont donc mises à nu
et lors des orages tropicaux violon et
bien les sédiments contaminés sont
lessivés et emportés jusque dans le
lagon calédonien qui est alors
contaminer la réhabilitation des sites
miniers est devenue une priorité pour le
gouvernement et un certain nombre de
chercheurs
notre laboratoire et c'est de développer
des techniques écologiques innovantes
pour participer à la réhabilitation de
sites miniers les plantes utilisées sont
des plantes locales
pionnière qui fonctionne comme l'arbre à
l'acf bleus vous en voyez ici quelques
images la première connue pour être une
plante ornementale pour les calédoniens
est pour nous une espèces pionnières
hyper accumulatrices de nickel les deux
suivantes révélé à exil rubgy n'osa
révéla meissner y sont deux plante
extrêmement résistante qu'on utilise en
phase de démarrage lorsque les sols sont
vraiment extrêmement dégradée ce sont
des accumulateurs de manganèse ces trois
espèces ont également d'autres
propriétés particulièrement intéressante
elle possède un système racinaire très
développés qui va permettre de
stabiliser le sol et ainsi d'éviter le
transport des sédiments vers le lagon
afin de le protéger
ces techniques de mise en oeuvre à
l'aide de ces plantes s'appelle la
phytoextraction la fuite aux extractions
une technique qui est quand même
relativement difficile subtil complexe à
mettre en oeuvre et elle doit prendre en
compte les contraintes locales
la première est l'altitude la plupart
des sites miniers
son attitude élevé ce qui constitue un
premier stress pour les espèces on
essaie de réimplanter le climat tropical
est une aux difficultés en nouvelle
calédonie on affaire à une alternance de
périodes sèches ou une tombe pas une
seule goutte d'eau et de périodes très
humide qui est l'objet d'orages violents
voire de cyclones ans qui emporte très
facilement nos jeunes plants enfin des
contraintes particulières liées à la
composition du sol ne sont pas simples à
résoudre ce sol est riche en toute une
série d'éléments métalliques toxiques
pour les plantes mais malheureusement
et pourvu en nutriments essentiels
vitaux pour la croissance des espèces
végétales
malgré ces difficultés et grâce au
support logistique et financier des
opérateurs miniers français qu'elle ait
de lien et bien nous avons réussi à
réhabiliter plus de 6 hectares avec
cette technique nouvelle de
phytoextraction ces procédés sont
relativement longs à mettre en oeuvre et
il a été clairement démontré qu'il était
nécessaire de trouver une valorisation
économique aux espèces végétales que
l'on utilisait en phytoextraction pour
qu'elle soit tout simplement durable
notre laboratoire a mis au point
très récemment cette première et unique
valorisation des espèces végétales
l'écho catalyse son principe est assez
simple
tirant parti de la capacités adaptatives
remarquable des espèces végétales a
accumulé les métaux bien nous
transformons directement les métaux
présents dans les feuilles en catalyseur
c'est à dire en outils chimiques qui
vont permettre de préparer un certain
nombre de biomolécules intéressante
grâce à l'éco catalyse et bien nous
avons réussi à préparer plus de 3500
biomolécules motivante
ces travaux ont été protégés par 25
brevets pris par le cnrs les
applications on a réussi à développer
sont les suivantes s'agit tout d'abord
de préparer des cosmétiques aux labels
bio ou naturels mais également des
molécules clé intermédiaire pour
l'industrie chimique des médicaments à
bas coûts tels que des agents antiviraux
des agents anticancéreux ou des
molécules actives contre le paludisme
enfin des biopesticides dits de nouvelle
génération car ils sont dépourvus des
côtes toxicité l'écho catalyse a été une
véritable opportunité pour essayer de
repenser la chimie l'art concevoir avec
une approche dite de chimie verte
c'est-à-dire une chimie qui va utiliser
exclusivement des produits naturels qui
va savoir
n'imitez la production de déchets fléau
majeur de la chimie actuelle limiter les
risques des procédés industriels
proposer des solutions des substituts
aux réactifs récemment interdit par la
réglementation européenne de la chimie
et enfin bien sûr développer des
procédés éco responsable aujourd'hui
cette combinaison inédite entre la
chimie et l'écologie est devenue une
véritable révolution verte
car pour la première fois la
réhabilitation des sites miniers n'est
plus une simple contrainte réglementaire
elle est devenue une opportunité
économique d'ailleurs une jeune
entreprise innovante en chimie verte a
choisi de donner une dimension
industrielle à l'ensemble de ses travaux
de recherche
on considère aujourd'hui que cette
technique est un véritable changement de
paradigme
car on peut voir que face aux problèmes
environnementaux que nous connaissons
tous il est possible d'agir concrètement
efficacement en proposant des solutions
écologiques viable l'économie verte
existe elle repose sur une approche
interdisciplinaire qui est sans préjugés
mais où la chimie et l'écologie se
complètent de façon positive et
constructive
merci à tous